Good morning everyone and welcome back after what I hope was a great spring
break.
This lecture that I'm going to deliver this morning has been an inspiration to
students who have selected option three for their paper topic.
How to design a Roman city because this lecture has it all.
It has great architecture.
It has an extraordinary patron,
a a man who traveled the empire to all kinds of exotic places that will,
some of which we'll be talking about today and some of which we'll be talking
about in the future.
A love triangle.
Uh,
some of the best buildings that we'll see in the course of some of the semester,
including the Pantheon and also Hadrian's villa at Tivoli,
the patron Hadrian.
Who am I show you in a portrait from Rome.
Now on the lefthand side of the screen,
uh,
it was an extraordinary man.
Uh,
he became,
he was born in 76,
Aad and he became emperor at the age of 41 after having served with Trajan for a
number of years.
He was born like Trajan before him in Spain,
not in Italy.
And,
uh,
he also was the most educated,
one of the most educated and most intellectual of the Roman emperors.
We'll talk about the impact that that intellect had on his architecture.
I mentioned that he already,
he also liked to travel.
He traveled extensively during his reign,
had three major,
uh,
major trips that had an enormous impact on his architecture and also on
architecture around the empire.
And it's also important I think to know that he reversed Trajan is policy.
You'll remember the Trajan is major,
a political policy had to do with military conquest that Trajan was involved in
a number of very important wars.
Uh,
and he celebrated those wars and he,
he extended the Empire to its furthest reaches,
reaches that were never gone beyond,
uh,
for the rest of the Roman empire.
Hadrian a reversed that policy.
He was a peace loving man.
He had no interest in being involved in these kinds of military exploits,
although he had served with Trajan in some of them in earlier years.
He had no desire to continue that on.
A auntie was much more concerned with,
uh,
consolidating and preserving the empire as expanded by Trajan.
And so one of his greatest claims to fame is the Great Wall,
the famous wall of Hadrian that he built a in order to separate the Roman
empire,
the Greco Roman Empire,
uh,
from the rest of the empire,
this Great Wall that divided Greco Roman civilization from the barbarian world
that lay outside.
And there are fragments of that wall.
It's quite extensive part of that wall that still survives in,
uh,
in,
in Europe today.
You can see it in Britain.
And I show you an example of some of those,
uh,
remains here on the right hand side of the screen that is of Hadrian's wall
Hadrian,
uh,
was also a great fill Helaine.
And you'll notice in that portrait that I just showed you that he wore a beard
and in fact,
he's the first Roman emperor to wear a beard.
Beards were not warned by Romans up to this time,
but they were worn by Greeks.
Uh,
and we believe that he wore that beard in large part to look more Greek.
We also know that although he wore a toga in public,
uh,
he was known for wearing the Greek high mation in private.
Uh,
and he did that we think in large part because of his love for Greece and for
Greek culture.
He was so filled Hellenic and his leanings that he received the nickname the
Greek ling.
And we'll see as we look at his architecture,
the impact that his love of Greece had on that architecture.
In fact,
what I'd like to do today is to begin with the most Greek of Hadrian's
buildings,
a building that we think he may have designed to himself.
Because we also know that Hadrian was an amateur architect.
Hadrian himself was an amateur architect,
uh,
and we think he designed this very building,
the so called Temple of Venus and Roma.
He was also particularly interested,
by the way in religious architecture,
most of his public building was religious architecture temples.
This being one of them,
the temple of Venus and Roma at temple put up to Roma as the patron goddess of
the city of Rome,
and to Venus as the patron goddess of the Roman family.
And you'll remember,
uh,
that Venus was a special favorite of Julius Caesar and of Augustus,
and they,
those two a thought of her as their,
as the special patron of the Julian family.
So we also see Hadrian here,
uh,
conjuring up,
I think his connections to the earlier dictators and Emperor Julius Caesar and
Augustus by his emphasis on Venus.
So this temple to Venus and Roma,
uh,
you'll see that we don't have a precise date for this monument.
We think it was put up some time between one 21 and 135 we know it was dedicated
in one 35.
It seems to have been long in the making.
So it's hard to categorize it as either an early or a mid or a late Hadrian Anik
building because it does seem to have been in production for quite some time.
I show you two plans of the temple of Venus and Roma because there's controversy
about which plan most accurately reflects the original Hadrian Anik temple,
uh,
because we know the temple,
was ball.
It was built under Hadrian and dedicated in one 35.
We know that it burned down in a very serious in Rome and the late third
century,
a d and then was renovated by uh,
a an emperor whom we'll talk about later in the semester by the name of Max
cinches and may x,
e n t.
I,
U s.
It was renovated by Max sensuous in 307,
a d.
Uh,
and uh,
we think Mexican just kept quite closely to the original adrianic plan a but
we're not absolutely sure about that so that some of the discrepancies that you
see between these two plans may have to do with the discrepancies between the
original building and the eventual renovation.
But,
uh,
you will see that in the main,
these two plans and the one on the left hand side of the screen is the one
that's on your monument lists that you have in front of you.
The one on the right hand side of the screen is the one in your Ward Perkins
Textbook.
But if you look at its most outstanding features,
you will see that most of them are similar to one another.
That the main features of these two buildings I have these two plans are the
same.
Uh,
and that is,
and you should be immediately struck by these plans,
both of these plans and how different they are from what we have characterized
as the typical Roman temple,
that typical Roman temple with usually with a single seller,
with a deep port,
with freestanding columns in that porch with a facade orientation.
This is very different indeed no matter which of these two plans you look at
because you will see that this large temple has a double seller to sell is back
to back and you see it in both plans to sell is back to back.
Well,
the reason for that is obvious because it commemorates to divinities Venus and
Roma and each one needed to have a cela but these are not sell side by,
these are not sellers within a larger Cela,
uh,
located side by side is in the capital.
I'm triad temple but rather two that are back to back to that are back to back.
Now what this does is take away the facade orientation of the building and give
us two facades in the sense,
one on either side,
uh,
that is also a,
so we see that in both of these.
We also see that the columns,
uh,
go all the way around the structure.
And so does the staircase go all the way around the structure.
We see that in both plants.
And then there was a large precinct that also has columns around it.
Uh,
I can also tell you can take on faith that this building also has a low podium.
So what we see here is a temple that looks much more Greek than it looks.
Roman.
In fact,
as I said,
it doesn't look anything like the typical Roman temples that we've been talking
about today.
Why is this?
This has to do with the fact that Hadrian was a Phil Halane,
that he was and Namor to Greek architecture and that he opted in this case when
he himself appears to have been the architect of this building.
Hadrian amateur architect seems to have designed this building himself.
A,
we see that when he was left entirely to his own,
he wanted to build a Greek temple in Rome.
And that is exactly what he did.
Now,
also important visa vi.
This temple is location,
location,
location.
This building is located on the,
at the edge of the Roman forum closest to the Colosseum.
Uh,
and on the Veolia you'll remember the Veolia where the arch of Titus is located.
the arch of Titus.
And you'll remember that that was the area that the Flavian dynasty chose,
uh,
to build their buildings on,
in order to raise to the ground Nero's earlier.
Don't,
don't miss transitory and build their own buildings in its place.
So we see Hadrian continuing on in that same tradition,
returning to the Roman people land that had originally been there as it had been
stolen by Nero,
uh,
by building,
in this case,
a religious structure on that site instead.
So that also extremely important to get back for a moment to the plan.
Uh,
we see again,
the major difference between these two versions is that in this case there is a
flat back wall for each of the individual sellers.
For this one,
I niche on either side and niches back tobacco must kissing as you can see here.
Uh,
and then you can also see another difference is the walls are very elaborately
scalped,
uh,
in this plan,
which we can see in the Max [inaudible] renovation that still exists.
And I'll show it to you in a moment.
Uh,
but again,
we're not sure if that was [inaudible] innovation in the early fourth century
ID.
Those back to back apps is and scalped walls or whether they come from the
original,
hey,
what did they read?
Restore what was in the original Adriatic building.
I tend to prefer the one on the left because there is every evidence that we
already have all of these features,
enrollment architecture,
think to the Flavian Palace on the Palatine demission palace,
uh,
where we saw the scallop walls in the Owl Reggio and where we certainly saw a,
these niches with vaults of heaven,
a semi don't 70 volts up above them.
So everything was in place,
uh,
to have that kind of structure.
So it's certainly not inconceivable in the Adriatic period.
Here's the view of the temple of Venus in Rome as it looks if you were standing
atop the coliseum and taking a picture back toward it.
And this is very useful,
uh,
because it shows you this is not a high podium.
This is just,
uh,
the,
the difference in ground level.
Once again,
uh,
ancient ground level being lower than modern ground level.
And some of the,
uh,
the,
the structures that lay below originally of Nero's a is transitory.
Or for example,
that this building was built on here.
You can actually see the podium of the temple and you can see that it is very
low compared to what we're used to.
We're looking back at one of those niches.
You can see the 70 dome,
uh,
as well as the relationship of it to the arch of Titus,
which ends the Veolia.
Which one again,
once again points out the fact that we are dealing here with a building that was
put on property that had originally been the location of Nero's Domus
transitory.
Here are three very useful views.
One showing that same niche closer up from the taken from the Colosseum,
one of those back to back niches as it looks today.
And then this one over here,
which is the other niche which is preserved inside a later building that was
transformed into a museum of the Forum Romana at one point we see it here and
you can see in both cases the 70 dome,
you can see the concrete construction faced with brick,
uh,
in this one,
which has better preserved in large part because it was in,
in pardon doors.
We can see the columns on either side of the niche.
And we also see that scallop wall that I described before,
just like the owl Reggio with niches flanked by columns.
And you can see the beginning of a coffered vaults.
We're not absolutely sure it was barrel vaulted,
but we think the building was barrel vaulted.
We also see on the left,
I remind you of the octagonal room designed by rebellious,
uh,
for the,
um,
dimensions palace on the Palatine to underscore again,
the kinds of experiments that rebellious was making that had such an impact.
As we shall see today on Hadrian and his own architectural designs.
You'll remember that room.
You'll remember that it has a segmented vault.
You will remember that it's treated very much like sculpture,
that it has niches,
that it has niches within,
niches,
windows within niches,
doorways within niches.
All of them done in an asymmetrical way.
A that makes the design particularly interesting,
rebellious,
and his architecture and very influential on Hadrian.
Uh,
keep in mind that Hadrian wants to mission.
I mentioned this to you when we talked about dimensions palace.
Once the mission built that palace,
it was the palace and all the emperor's from that time to the end of late
antiquity lived in Hadrian was no exception.
When he was in Rome.
He lived in that palace and he was there for seeing and experiencing,
uh,
the shapes of the architectural shapes designed by [inaudible] on a daily basis.
He liked that octagonal room in particular and the others like it in the villa
in the palace.
And he was clearly,
it clearly had an impact on him as we shall see.
The last point I want to make about the temple of Venus enrollment by the way,
has to do with materials.
We have been talking about the increasing use of marble enrollment architecture
under Augustus marble from Luna or Carrara under Nero and the flavor Ian's
marble from all over the world from Asia minor from Africa of all different
colors.
Hadrian the fill of Elaine returns to using Greek marble,
uh,
for his buildings.
And the Temple of Venus in Roma is made,
uh,
proclination marble p.
I am,
I think I got that right.
Proclination marble,
uh,
that um,
that comes from Greece.
It's a blue veined marble.
He was particularly fond of it and he used it for the temple of Venus and Roma.
I want to turn from the temple of Venus enrollment to the much more famous
temple that Hadrian constructed.
If the temple of Venus and Roma was to two gods,
I mean this in Roma.
Uh,
the Hadrian Hadrian's pantheon was to all the gods,
which is what pantheon means to all the gods at temple,
to all the gods,
uh,
that he built in Rome between one 18 and 128 a d you see a Google earth image of
it here,
the Pantheon surrounded by,
uh,
by modern structures.
It is one of the greatest masterpieces of architecture of all times.
Uh,
in fact,
if you were to ask a group of architectural experts to give,
make a list of their 10,
the 10 greatest buildings ever built,
it's hard for me to believe that not every one of them would at least list
somewhere in that list of 10,
the Pantheon,
not only because it's a great building in its own right,
but because it has had such a,
an enormous impact on architecture in Roman times as we'll see in later
lectures,
but also on architecture in post antique times and extraordinarily influential
building.
And there are some,
and I would be one of them.
Maybe I'd be the only one.
I hope not.
Uh,
who would list the Pantheon as the greatest building ever built by man or woman
of any time in any place.
And you can see as we look at it together today,
whether you think I come closer,
I'm way off the mark on that,
but I believe vehemently that it was the greatest building ever built.
And it remains an extraordinary structure to see and to experience.
You see it here.
Oh,
and by the way,
although I mentioned that Hadrian was an amateur architect,
we don't know the name of the architect for the Pantheon.
Do I think it was Hadrian?
Absolutely not.
Hadrian was not this good.
It was an amateur architect,
not a professional architect.
This is an extraordinary work of art.
He may have had some input.
He undoubtedly did.
Uh,
because we're going to see that the Pantheon is at the same time complex and
simple.
Uh,
it's also traditional and innovative.
And what we're going to see Hadrian and his architect doing here and also doing
it.
The villa at Tivoli is combining in an extraordinary way,
traditional Roman and innovative Roman architecture,
concrete construction,
and the original vocabulary of Greek architecture,
namely columns combined in the same place.
And he was highly influenced in this regard by his predecessor Trajan.
Think of the markets and forum of Trajan,
the way in which we had combined in the same complex,
a traditional forum and a very innovative marketplace.
We're going to see the same thing in the Pantheon.
We're going to see the same thing at Hadrian's villa at Tivoli.
So Trajan exerting of Trajan and Apollo,
Doris of Damascus exerting a very strong influence as did robberies on the
architecture of Hadrian.
Uh,
again,
this,
this a Google earth image is useful because it shows us the building in its
modern environment.
Uh,
but it's important to keep in mind that the Pantheon in Rome,
uh,
was part of a complex in antiquity as most temples were temples that were in
sanctuary samples that were in fora.
We've seen that in the course of the semester that they usually did not stand in
isolation,
but we're part of architectural complexes.
We see that here of this model is very helpful in that regard because it shows
us that there was a rectangular court that that for court had covered colonnades
on either side,
that there was some sort of entranceway here,
possibly an arch,
possibly an altar,
also a to all the gods in front of the temple.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
the temple itself,
the Pantheon itself.
Now this model is also very useful in the sense that it gives you an idea of
what you actually would have seen if you had walked into,
uh,
this complex into this open rectangular space,
and walked toward the,
the Pantheon.
What would you actually have seen?
Well,
all that you would have actually seen was the porch,
the porch,
which had an attic behind it,
which screened,
uh,
the cylindrical drum and the dome from the viewer.
So if you were standing here,
all you would have seen was this porch.
Now this porch is very traditional.
It looks like other Roman temples,
the fronts of facades of Roman temples that we've looked up before.
It looks like other Greek temples,
uh,
because what you would've seen a was the pediment columns supporting that
pediment.
It was a typical Roman temple from the top front,
deep porch,
freestanding columns in that porch,
single staircase facade orientation,
very different from the temple of Venus and Roma,
much more Roman looking.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
I think I,
and then I high podium a high podium,
which we already mentioned,
the temple of Venus enrollment did not have,
that's what you would have seen as you were standing in front of it.
You would have thought,
well,
this is very much in keeping with other Roman temples.
Uh,
but,
uh,
of course there was a surprise when one walk through the doors.
And that is the very essence of adrianic architecture.
Uh,
the surprise that one gets when one actually goes from the outside of building
into the inside of a building.
Before we do that,
I just want to show you the back of the cylindrical because this,
this,
uh,
traditional porch,
shielded,
uh,
a very innovative cylindrical drum supported by a hemispherical dome.
As you can see here,
uh,
the construction technique,
the same as we've seen,
uh,
from the time of Augustus,
from the time of the temple of Mercury at Baia,
the use of concrete construction faced with brick.
It's more sophisticated here than it has ever been before.
And we can see that the artists have,
the architect has relieved the severity of the structure by adding a three
cornices.
You can see them here,
two of them at least.
Heres another one down here,
three cornices.
And you can also see very interestingly,
these brick arches which tell us a great deal about Roman building practice
during this period,
especially obviously for the use of concrete construction because what those
were used for is to help keep the uh,
concrete from settling after the,
the wet concrete had been poured.
Those arches keep it from settling until it dries.
And then once it dries,
uh,
those arches are no longer needed because the building,
the concrete walls support the building on their own,
can support the dome on their own and they're no longer needed,
but of course they're left there and then they have a certain aesthetic value in
the aftermath.
Uh,
and so you can see very clearly here as you look at what is preserved and the
building is extremely well preserved of the back of the building.
Uh,
you can see a reference to that construction,
uh,
these diagrams,
both the plan,
the plan of the structure of the cross section and the diagram on the left hand
side also give us some very interesting and important information.
Uh,
they show us that the,
um,
circular drum was internally half the height of the diameter.
You can see that in the,
uh,
in the diagram on the left hand side of the screen,
of the diameter of the structure and,
um,
that it was surmounted by a hemispherical dome,
the Crown of which is,
uh,
the,
the exact distance,
the same exact distance.
So this was very carefully orchestrated by the architect to achieve,
uh,
what he needed to achieve here.
Uh,
you can also see if you look at the plan that again,
uh,
the,
the predecessors for this are clearly the frigging Daria at palm pay,
the thermal bath at Baia.
This round structure with the radiating apps is a very similar but of course
done in much,
much grander scale.
Now with regard to,
with regard to,
and this is the facade of the Pantheon of course as it looks today with regard
to how they made this happen,
how they were able to take the small scale frigging Daria,
uh,
the slightly larger temple of Mercury,
the larger still don't miss our area of neuro or the Dome Dome.
The Dome is transitory and turn it into the Pantheon ultimately has to do in
part not only with the skill of the architects has to do in part also with the
increasing sophistication that we've been talking about quite consistently of
the use of concrete construction by the Romans.
Uh,
but also has to do with the recipe for concrete.
We haven't talked about the recipe for concrete since the time of [inaudible]
when we talked about the fact that he had made some adjustments,
well Hadrian made some adjustments or Hadrian and his architects made some
adjustments as well,
uh,
during Hadrian's reign.
Uh,
and what they did was they,
two things,
they decreased the,
um,
thickness.
They decrease the thickness of the walls,
uh,
from bottom to top.
Uh,
and they also did what collegial had done before,
but did it even even more so by,
uh,
mixing,
using as an aggregate at the base of the dome.
They used a heavy,
heavy stone,
a result,
very heavy,
thick,
bizarre old.
But when they got toward the top,
they mixed,
or the idea was when they got toward the top,
they would mix in as an aggregate I porous pumice,
which was much,
much lighter.
And that's essentially how they achieved their goals.
Now,
before I talk about the exterior of the structure and,
and take you through the building,
I want to mention one very interesting exchange between Hadrian and Trajan is
architect Apollo Doris of Damascus.
You'll remember that I said that the temple of Venus and Roma we think was
designed by Hadrian himself.
And at one point Adrian Mapala,
Doris was still alive and at one point and highly respected.
And at one point Hadrian went to Apollo,
Doris to ask him for his thoughts on the designs that Hadrian was doing or the
plans and Hadrian was doing for the temple of Venus in Roma,
which tells us,
do you wondered where I got,
where I,
how we know that Hadrian was an amateur architect.
It's because of this passage because it tells us that Hadrian was doing some
designing and that he was designing the temple of Venus and Roma.
And we fortunately have the,
the uh,
Roman senator of eastern birth.
Dyo Cassius Dio,
new words,
Ca Ssi,
you s oh,
caches,
a Roman senator of eastern birth who wrote a history of Rome in the third
century,
gives us the third century ID,
gives us,
uh,
an account of this interaction between Hadrian and Apollo.
Doris of Damascus.
And although I don't like to read to you,
I am going to read to you from this quote because it is so critical for our
understanding both of the Pantheon and four Hadrian's villa at Tivoli.
So bear with me as I read this,
you know,
a bit long dish,
um,
quote.
So Cassius Cassius diode tells us,
and I quote,
Hadrian first drove into exile and then put to death Apollo Doris,
who had carried out many of Trajan building projects.
The pretext given for Hadrian's action was Apollo.
Doris had been guilty of some serious offense,
but the truth is that when Trajan was at one time consulting with the Paula
Doris about a certain problem connected with his buildings,
that is Trajan is buildings.
The architect said to Hadrian.
So this seems to have been before even Hadrian I became emperor,
the architect said to Hadrian who had interrupted them with some advice,
go away and draw your pumpkin's.
You know nothing about these problems for it.
So happened that Hadrian was at that time prided himself on some sort of drawing
when he became emperor.
That is when Hadrian became emperor.
He remembered the insult and refuse to put up with Apollo and refuse to put up
with Apollo,
adores his outspokenness.
He sent him the plan for the Temple of Venus and Roma in order to demonstrate
that it was possible for a great work to be conceived without a politic Chris's
help and asked him that his Hadrian asked to Paula doors if he thought the
building was well designed.
Apollo Doris sent a reply saying that as far as the temple of Venus and Roma was
concerned,
it should have been placed in a higher position.
It should have had a high podium,
not a low podium,
according to a Paula Doris who goes on to say with regard to the cult images,
Apollo,
Doris Kapala doors goes on to say with regard to the cult images,
they were made on a scale which was too great for the height of the Sella for if
the goddesses should wish to stand up and leave the temple.
He said they would be unable to do so when he wrote all of this so bluntly,
Hadrian was both irritated and deeply pained.
He had the man slain.
Now the Pumpkin's,
what's critical about this?
It tells us two things that are absolutely essential in our understanding of
adrianic architecture.
One that Hadrian was doing,
designing on his own,
that he was an amateur architect and he seems to be very much involved in the
design of the temple of Venus and Roma.
It also tells us that Hadrian was making some drawings,
uh,
of pumpkin domes.
What our pumpkin domes.
Well,
pub pumpkin drones or domes are undoubtedly segmented domes.
They are just the kind of dome that rubbery barriers did for the octagonal rooms
in the palatine palace rooms that Hadrian was exposed to by living in that
palace himself.
Obviously fond of them like them,
uh,
started to draw his own pumpkins and we're going to see that,
that those pumpkin's well,
we don't have a pumpkin dome in the Pantheon and this won't see probably
fortunately.
Uh,
but uh,
we do have them at Hadrian's villa.
And so again,
very critical,
uh,
for you to be aware of this.
It's interesting exchange,
very momentous exchange between Hadrian and Apollo.
Doris,
we see here the facade of the Pantheon as it looks today.
You have to think a way,
this very attractive,
but nonetheless,
uh,
Mars,
the view of the,
of the facade of the Pantheon that was put up in the renaissance,
uh,
and you have to imagine the building now stands in isolation without it's
colonnades and without it's for court.
So you have to try to imagine them,
but you can see how very well preserved the Pantheon is.
Uh,
the ground level has shifted so we don't see the very tall podium that was once
there,
although there have been some excavations around it that demonstrate that it is
indeed,
there are part of it is indeed there.
Uh,
but we can see the columns across the front.
We can see an inscription,
we can see the pediment and the attic.
And this is a good view because although you see the dome peeping up a little
bit on the top,
it gives you some sense of when you stood in the colonnade,
walking toward it,
uh,
that the,
the forecourt walking toward it,
that you would have only seen essentially the most traditional part of the
building.
And that is the columns supporting the pediment with the Dome behind.
This is a detail of the inscription of the building.
Uh,
we can also see the columns.
You can see that they are gray.
Granted,
I've a better view in a moment.
Gray granite with white marble capitals.
The inscription is fascinating.
It tells us that m.
Dot.
At grip up.
Marcus Agrippa,
that's the famous Marcus Agrippa,
the childhood friend,
confidant,
son in law firsthand.
Man.
One time air,
uh,
to Augustus.
Marcus Agrippa LF lucious Phil,
he is the son of Lucius Cos coast,
a console consult tear team for the third time.
Fake it made it,
this tells us Marcus Agrippa console for the third time son of Lucius made it,
made the Pantheon.
What's that all about?
Marcus Agrippa lived in the age of Augustus.
Well,
we know there was an earlier pantheon on this site that Marcus Agrippa was
responsible for commissioning.
Marcus Agrippa like a Augustus commissioned a lot of buildings in Rome.
He also commissioned them in the provinces.
We'll look at some of those when we go out to the provinces.
Marcus Agrippa major building program in Rome,
including a pantheon,
a temple to all the gods.
And we don't,
that Pantheon no longer exists,
although there've been some excavations that have discovered some of it
underneath the current building.
Uh,
but it stood on this very site and we know from a literary description that had
had a car he porch,
which is perhaps not surprising in the context of Augustan architecture.
Remember the car he audits in the forum of Augustus,
uh,
that we looked at earlier in the term.
So we know that Marcus Agrippa actually built Rome's first Pantheon,
both its first temple to the gods on this very site.
When Hadrian built his own Pantheon on the same site,
he decided to piously reference,
uh,
the earlier building of Marcus Agrippa telling us that Marcus Agrippa made this,
made a building that originally stood on this site,
which he is basically very modestly saying he restored.
Of course,
this building that he made has nothing to do undoubtedly with the Pantheon
enrollments,
a very different and much more sophisticated building.
But it was a very modest thing to do.
But I think there was a,
uh,
you know,
a method to his madness in the sense that he,
he,
he was underscoring by so doing his relationship once again to Augustus,
which was obviously very important for him to do.
But this inscription confused a lot of scholars for a long time who actually
called this originally a,
um,
an Augustan building.
You can see the pediment up above.
You can see all the holes there.
Those are the attachment marks for sculpture that would have stood in that would
have been located in this pediment that no longer survives.
Here's another view showing the gray,
the light gray granite columns,
the white Corinthian capitals,
all of these VR magnificently carved,
very high quality artists,
architects and artisans here.
By the way,
I forgot to mention when we talked about the temple of Venus and Roman,
the use of Greek marble that Hadrian not only abroad in Greek marble,
but he brought in Greek marble cutters,
marble carvers,
uh,
who were responsible for working on these.
So he wanted the very best,
those who are most familiar with carbon,
Greek marble,
uh,
to be used for his buildings.
And they were undoubtedly used for this one as well.
Uh,
and we can see the depth of the porch.
I think also from this view of the Corinthian columns of that porch,
it's very hard in a classroom,
in new haven,
even with outstanding slides,
uh,
to be able to give you a sense of the experience that one has of the surprise
that one has as one walks through the door of the Pantheon.
Uh,
we see,
uh,
the door's open tier.
They are bronze doors,
they are original drawer door doors from this extremely well preserved
structure.
And the reason that it is so well preserved is because like other buildings in
Rome,
it was reused in later times as a church,
primarily with a wonderful name Santa Maria Rotunda,
Saint Mary,
the Rotunda,
Mary essentially,
uh,
which is perfectly,
perfectly chosen,
uh,
for a building with a giant Rotunda with a great cylindrical drum that the
building has a,
we see those doors opened up here and as one walks through this very traditional
porch through the original bronze doors into the interior,
uh,
one is struck by the extraordinary nature of the interior of the Pantheon,
which you see over here.
And all you're looking at here is the upper most part,
uh,
with the,
with the Dome essentially because,
and the reason is because it is near the Hue.
Even the human eye,
both eyes can't take in,
uh,
the,
the extent of this interior all in one glance.
And even if one uses the widest of wide angle lenses,
you get a tremendous amount of distortion I knew,
can't really take the whole thing in at once,
which is what makes it extraordinary.
And one has to rely instead on this painting by Panini that shows you the grand
jury beneath the dome.
That gives you a better idea that any image I can show you however professional
of what the interior of the Pantheon actually looks like.
A,
and you can see in this Panini painting,
uh,
the wonderful marble revetment,
the marble floor,
uh,
the,
the Dome,
uh,
with its coffers.
There are,
um,
uh,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
five rows have five rows of 28 coffers each 140 coffers and all,
uh,
they were likely gilded in antiquity.
You see that there is an oculus through which light streams down onto that
gilding down onto the marble in cross station,
the marble incrustation by the way,
extremely well preserved.
This is about our best example of ancient Roman marble.
Not all of it is ancient,
but a good portion of it is,
and it gives you a very good sense of what some of these marble buildings would
have looked like in antiquity.
And I show you a detail of some of the original marble revetment over here.
And this is what those palm pains wished.
Their walls actually were.
A beautiful marbles of all different colors brought from all different parts of
the world.
So even though Hadrian chose proclination marble or his temple of Venus and
Roma,
his Greek building,
which we really need to think of as a kind of Greek import,
a for this more Roman building,
he is following in the footsteps of narrow and the Flavian and using
multicolored marble both for the revetment on the wall and the marble pavement
down below.
Uh,
most of this building,
again,
it's very well preserved.
It's original is the original structure,
the original columns,
the original pilasters still extremely well preserved and the Pantheon,
uh,
because it was used over time as a church.
There are lots of accouterments that one would expect a in a church,
uh,
various saints and niches and so on and so forth.
So much of the sculpture,
uh,
is,
is from a later period.
And it even served a,
has served as a burial place for famous,
uh,
Italians,
not the least of which was Rafael,
the famous renaissance painter who hold your remember left to graffito when he
went down,
uh,
into the subterranean chambers of Nero's.
Don't miss our area.
He was buried here in his tomb is one of the high points,
but most visitors to this structure,
you see it here,
uh,
dwarfs to most people's minds.
The tumor,
Victor Emmanuel,
uh,
whom you see over here on the left hand side of the screen.
But note all of that Roman symbolism.
You know,
the Eagle without stretch wings and the Amazonian Pelton.
So on all of those of Roman power,
a still very much used by dynastic modern dynasty like Victor Emmanuel,
the Dome of the Pantheon had the largest diameter of any dome,
uh,
up to this point.
Uh,
we know that it was,
the diameter of the Pantheon is 142 feet.
And,
uh,
if we compare it to the other large dome in Rome,
that of Saint Peters,
uh,
we find that the Pantheon Dome still surpasses Saint Peter.
Saint Peter's is 139 feet in diameter.
So just a bit smaller.
Now,
any of you who have been both in the Pantheon and in Saint Peters will probably
say to me,
wait a minute here.
Uh,
the Dome of Saint Peter's actually looks larger when you stand in front
underneath it.
And I show you a view of that dome here.
The reason it does look a bit larger is the Dome of Saint Peter's is taller.
So volume metrically it looks bigger.
Uh,
and visually it looks bigger,
but it isn't in terms of its diameter in diameter.
The Dome of the Pantheon is still the largest dome in the city of Rome.
And as you look at this dome and compare it to Saint Peter's one can't help but
think and think back to uh,
demission and his dominus at de [inaudible] and his Baltz and so on and so
forth.
The whole idea of being,
uh,
having the Dome of Heaven over one's head,
I think one can't help but think when one looks at this,
that there may be some reference here,
both to the orb of the earth.
And to the Dome of Heaven.
And it is certainly,
uh,
a,
um,
a appropriate symbol for a building that honors all the gods.
I think it's important to,
um,
to at this juncture to say something about or to compare,
uh,
the most important Greek temple,
the Parthenon on the Acropolis in Athens with the most significant Roman temple,
the Pantheon,
uh,
to see that we have really come from an exterior to an interior architecture.
Then in the case of the Parthenon,
fifth century BC,
the Indian Necropolis,
uh,
they are thinking primarily of a building that interacts with the rock of the
Acropolis and with the urban landscape.
Uh,
and in other contexts,
these Greek buildings interact directly with nature.
That's the way the Greeks thought about their buildings essentially as an
exterior structure.
And we see the Romans following suit in their emphasis on facade,
the facade of temples in their own religious architecture.
But with the Pantheon that changes,
yes,
it does have a facade does have a pediment in the front.
It does have a traditional porch.
So that's a nod to traditional temple architecture.
But once you go through that port into the structure and see that great a
cylindrical drum,
the hemispherical dome,
the light streaming through a,
you're in,
this is totally new interior world that has no precedent in early Roman
architecture.
And that had a huge impact on later Byzantine architecture,
medieval,
especially Byzantine architecture.
And particularly go to Istan,
Valencia,
Aya,
Sophia or the blue mosque.
They owe everything to the dome of the Pantheon.
So we see this final,
this real transition here,
a transition also in building materials from stone to concrete construction.
A few more views of this,
um,
of the interior of the dome,
the Dome of the Pantheon.
These are very dramatic in black and white.
Uh,
and you can see it's,
it's just if you're in Rome and half the time it's great deal of fun to go and
look at the Pantheon at different times of day because the light has such an
impact on what the interior looks like.
You know,
go,
go in there in the morning,
take a look,
then go out of a long lunch,
glass of wine,
come back later and see,
see what has happened.
And it's also fun to be there when it rains.
It's interesting.
Does have the rain come down and collect?
There is a drain but it doesn't always work all that well.
So I see water collecting on the edges of the floor in this extraordinary
building.
A one last view.
I love taking views of the,
I mean I take Xyz Zillions of images that I've taken,
including this one of the interior of the Pantheon at all different times of
day.
But I think it behooves us to notice and to say that,
uh,
in,
in this kind of new interior architecture,
this architecture of interiors surprise,
uh,
it's not only the vault itself,
it's not only the concrete construction or the marble revetment light plays a
very important role and we've seen light playing a very important role from the
times of the,
uh,
the domains of the dome.
Is he tall Laika,
uh,
up through and the sanctuary at terror Cina for example,
up to where we are today,
but never more important than here.
Light that streams through the oculus light that is used not only to aluminate
this building and illuminated extremely well,
but also to create drama,
to create drama.
And you have to imagine it even more dramatic when they,
when the coppers were gilded.
Uh,
and when the marble down below may have been even brighter still.
the marble pavement by the way,
which I didn't show you,
is also extremely well preserved.
So this light,
this light plays a very important and dramatic role in this new highly developed
interior architecture.
And,
uh,
I know I personally know of no other building that one can visit and experience
that gives you a better sense than this one of the divine presence on earth,
whether it's one god,
multi gods.
As we're honored here,
you really get a sense of spirituality when you stand in this extraordinary,
uh,
temple and really do get a sense of the divine presence.
I think on earth I mentioned that the Pantheon has,
has spawned lots of you has lots of buildings and be cloned from the Pantheon
both in ancient times.
And I'll show you a couple of examples later in the semester,
but also in more modern times.
There are lots of examples.
Woolsey Hall for example,
here on campus is a kind of a pantheon.
Uh,
but,
uh,
look,
look at the most,
the most obvious example in the United States is,
uh,
the not only Monte Cello,
but also Thomas Jefferson's University of Virginia,
the Rotunda at the University of Virginia,
which you see here is clearly based exactly on the Pantheon.
Thomas Jefferson,
a great fan of ancient architecture.
His library,
his personal library has lots of books on Roman architecture,
but I lost,
you know,
when you look at a view of the Rotunda and the lawn at the University of
Virginia,
I told my first teaching job was at Uva,
taught there for three years.
Uh,
but,
um,
uh,
when you look at this,
when you look at this building or the lawn at Uva with the Rotunda,
you can't help but wonder if Thomas Jefferson didn't know,
uh,
that the Pantheon in Rome had that for court because the,
the,
the Rotunda faces that the wrong way faces this way.
But nonetheless,
he's got behind it,
uh,
in,
in his own design,
uh,
this extraordinary rectangular court that does conjure up a exactly what the
pantheon looked like in Rome.
A few very quick,
uh,
views of the Pantheon.
I just hate to let it go.
Uh,
but just some quick views of the Pantheon.
one of the best ways of seeing it.
It's surrounded by not only a wonderful Piatsa,
which is a great place to eat,
Gelato,
or have a glass of wine.
Uh,
but,
uh,
there are,
you can,
you can encounter it from a number of narrow streets and that whole element of
surprise is still there.
You know,
you're walking along the street and wow,
all of a sudden there it is in front of you.
And you can see that very well here as you begin to get a glimpse of it with
regard to eating around the Pantheon.
I recommend one of my absolute favorite restaurants in Rome,
which is a easy to remember because it's for,
to,
not to all pantheon.
You see it over here with its,
um,
wonderful outdoor space and it's white,
uh,
White,
um,
umbrella's,
uh,
right across from the Pantheon,
directly across is a Mcdonald's.
Uh,
I never,
you know,
the Golden Arches are really very much like a Roman aqueduct,
don't you think?
So references the,
I told you there were residences everywhere of Rome.
Don't eat it.
You know,
you can eat a McDonald's anytime.
Go to go to the other one.
Um,
much more interesting and it has the best.
I've never had this anywhere else.
It has,
um,
a veal Scallopini all Gorgonzola with Gorgonzola,
very thin,
a layer of Gordon's delicious.
Uh,
I also told you I was going to keep you abreast of the latest on Gelato in Rome.
We've talked about trace Collini,
so I just wanted to show you della Della Panna.
If you're standing at the Pantheon restaurant,
look to the right.
You're going to see della Paul Mopey,
AOL and a,
it's a of the four best.
Actually,
I think it's the fourth.
It's not my absolute favorite,
but if you like,
it's a little bit more Americanized.
As you can see from this selection.
Notice their Mars Bar speechy Ali tar,
uh,
as well as some of their other flavors.
My favorite personal favorite is up by owning,
which you see over here.
But just to whet your appetite early in the morning,
I want to move in the,
in the,
um,
20 minutes or so that remain,
I would like to move from the Pantheon in Rome to Hadrian's home,
not as home in Rome,
which is,
we've mentioned was the palace of demission on the Palatine Hill,
but his Rome activity is his villa at Tivoli Tivoli,
ancient Tibor.
We've talked about Tivoli many times before where the marble,
the travertine quarries are located.
Tivoli Tivoli is about of a,
I dunno,
40 minute drive from Rome today,
kind of high speed drive from Rome today.
Uh,
but in antiquity longer obviously,
but not inaccessible from Rome.
It was Hadrian.
Obviously you had no problems getting there in ancient Roman times.
It's an extraordinary place.
Uh,
and Hadrian it was a,
it was a place that Hadrian used as a kind of incubator for his architectural
ideas.
And it's highly likely that many of the,
of the,
of the buildings that we see there were designed in part by him,
especially those famous pumpkin dumps.
Cause we're gonna see that a number of these buildings do indeed have pumpkin
domes designed under the influence of the architecture of rebellious.
It's an amazing below it is the most extensive villa preserved from the Roman
world and likely the most grand of all the Roman villas.
And if we think back to Nero's palace in Rome,
what made Nero's palace in Rome so scandalous,
uh,
was the fact that it was located in downtown Rome.
Uh,
but if you compare Nero's palace,
uh,
to,
to Hadrian's villa activity,
there's no comparison between the two.
Hadrian's villa activity is much more extensive.
It has a much more extraordinary buildings from the architectural standpoint.
Uh,
and it was decorated even more opulently with a wide variety of sculpture,
mosaics and paintings.
It was clearly an extraordinary place.
And if,
if Trajan is forum,
was in a sense a microcosm of the extent of the empire under Trajan,
I like to think of Hadrian's villa,
uh,
as,
the empire under Hadrian,
the empire that he traveled around so many times.
And I show you in the upper right,
a map of the Roman empire,
all of that orange area is the area that was under Rome's Egis,
uh,
at the time of Trajan and into the years of Hadrian.
And if you look closely,
you will see three colored lines,
a yellow,
a blue,
and a red line.
Those are Hadrian's travels around the empire.
And it shows you how extensive they were.
He went everywhere.
Why?
Because he loved to travel.
He just loved to travel.
Uh,
but he also went in order to take a look at a provincial affairs at firsthand.
Now,
everywhere he went,
he either he himself paid for buildings that were erected or more often than
that,
buildings were put up by local,
uh,
local magistrates and so on.
Local cities,
uh,
in honor of Hadrian.
Uh,
in order to try to get a favor out of him or just to honor him on his visit.
Some of these were rushed,
you know,
put up in a rush job in order to be there when he arrived on the scene.
So we see this incredible array of building activity,
uh,
during this period,
and we will see that reflected as we make our way.
Um,
beginning already next week,
wake our way into the provinces.
We will begin to see some very interesting,
hey adrianic buildings in those provinces that reflect what he was doing
elsewhere or in Rome.
But what we see here,
what we see at the villa is fascinating because all of us were just back from
break.
Some of you did some traveling.
We know that traveling expands all of our horizons.
We go someplace experientially were different than we were before by what we see
and what we experience.
And we also,
um,
maybe not in this new economic climate,
but at least in the past,
we all tended to pick up souvenirs,
you know,
t shirt here and whatever their handbag there.
Uh,
and,
um,
and we bring those back to remind us,
remind us and make us,
you know,
have memories of the wonderful trip that we took.
Well,
Hadrian did that as well.
He collected souvenirs,
but because of his own wealth and because he had the imperial treasury behind
him,
he could,
he could collect buildings as souvenir essentially.
So when Hadrian traveled and saw what he liked,
what he did was he came back to this laboratory,
this architectural laboratory that he had at Tivoli a and t either created,
some of these were probably designed by him,
others by his architects.
He created a series of buildings that were in a sense souvenirs of his travels,
either exact duplicates of things he saw or variations on those themes.
And it makes these buildings particularly fascinating to look at the,
uh,
the,
the villa of Hadrian was,
uh,
had three,
three,
essentially three building phases and early a middle and a late,
uh,
they span the entire,
attire,
um,
reign of Hadrian.
Uh,
this,
this villa was clearly Hadrian's hobby as well as his home.
And if he hadn't died in one 38,
he would have undoubtedly continued to build here.
So these buildings go up throughout the course of Hadrian's reign.
I show you a view from the air of the villa.
As it looks today,
you can see that there are a series of very attractive pools of water
interspersed with architecture.
Uh,
if look at a plan of the villa,
you will see that it is different than any other villa we've seen before in
that,
uh,
these buildings are actually kind of casually,
almost in an ad hoc way,
arranged around nature to interact with nature.
We don't see the axiology and the symmetry that is so characteristic of so much
of Roman architecture.
They kind of meander along as you might expect,
architectural experiments to man to meander.
And it has everything there.
Not only pools,
but a wide variety of buildings that I'm going to show you fairly fleetingly.
Uh,
this great island villa over here,
uh,
the Piatsa Dora Dora or the Golden Plaza,
the,
um,
the two sets of baths,
a large bath and a small bowel.
So you also see a stadium here,
hairpin shape that I'm not going to return to the Canopius another pool.
This was so complete that it even had its own Haiti's its own hell.
Uh,
in the villa.
Everything was here.
Hadrian left no stone unturned.
I want to show you in fairly quick succession examples of the most interesting
buildings of these,
uh,
tourist souvenirs that Hadrian brings back from his travels.
The first I'd like to show you is the so called Temple of Venus,
which belongs to the latest building phase at the villa one 33 to 138.
This is Hadrian the fill Helene once again,
just as we saw him at the temple of Venus and Roma,
he goes to the Greek island of [inaudible],
k n I d o s,
the Greek island of tonight us on which there was the most famous round temple
of Venus with the most famous Greek statue of Venus.
Uh,
a statue by the great Greek sculptor Prac siddeleys.
Lots of people went to see it.
And interestingly enough,
it was this,
uh,
this,
temple and the statue,
a excavated in a number of decades ago by a woman wrote female archeologist with
the perfect name Iris love for the goddess of land.
That was really her name,
destined to go excavate.
Uh,
the,
uh,
temple of the goddess of love on the Greek island of [inaudible].
Hadrian goes there.
He's enraptured by what he sees.
He bills at his villa,
an exact replica and exact replica of this Greek round temple.
Uh,
you can see it's the doric order.
You can see it supports triglycerides and met apiece.
And then in the center,
uh,
a statue of Venus,
unfortunately now headless and RM lists,
that's a cast.
The original is in the museum on the site.
You see it in the museum on the site over here,
uh,
based on practice siddeleys earlier,
statue.
There are lots of copies of this famous praxis telian statute.
We see another one here in the Vatican.
Uh,
that's more complete,
gives you a better sense of what it looked like.
But again,
here are the door at columns and the triglyceride metaphase.
So the most important point for you,
an exact replica in this particular case,
the most extraordinary of these,
uh,
sort of architectural conceits,
these giant,
a tourist souvenirs that Hadrian brings back from his travels to his villa
activity is the so called Canopius add Hadrian's villa.
My personal favorite,
the CANopen Canopius at Hadrian's villa,
which you see on your monument list,
also dating to the latest period one 33 to 138 a d it is meant to conjure up in
this case,
not Greece,
but Egypt,
uh,
a canal,
the canal opus in Egypt.
That was a tributary of the Nile.
Uh,
and we know that you could travel from Alexandria to a small town called
Canopius by means of this canal.
And that is what is meant to be conjured up here.
The city of CANopen had in it a temple to the Egyptian gods.
Cerasis,
s e r a p I s arap is who was the healing God.
And people came from all around the world to be healed at the temple of
[inaudible].
It was also well known as a place with a wonderful amusement park.
Uh,
and we think that all hell though Hadrian seems to have gone there,
uh,
in part to go to the sanctuary of syrup as he also appears to have gone there
because it was also an amusement park.
And this is where we get into the personal love triangle of Hadrian.
Hadrian was married to a woman by the name of Sabina,
a very beautiful woman,
but you've does look kind of Dour,
uh,
in this portrait on the right hand side of the screen.
So perhaps we don't blame him for taking up with what must have been the most
beautiful boy and all of antiquity.
A youth by the name of Ann [inaudible],
a n t,
I n o,
u s and Tinto is whom Hadrian met on his travels in Asia minor smitten with the
boy.
Uh,
and they became constant companions thereafter.
but unfortunately antenna was while still very young,
died by drowning where else?
But the Nile in Egypt also on these travels,
they went to Canopius together,
by the way,
to the amusement park.
Uh,
but poor antenna was died by drowning in the Nile.
No one knows exactly what happened.
Was it an accident?
Some say that he may have given his life to save Hadrian's we don't really know.
That's never been sorted out as to exactly what happened to this love this,
this wonderful and beautiful young man.
Um,
but he died by drowning in the Nile,
which made the Nile a particularly poignant spot,
uh,
for Hadrian who appears to have recreated it here at his villa.
He also went on to found,
this is one of the reasons this has inspired so many design your own Roman
cities project.
Not only the relationship between Hadrian and antenna was and this love triangle
with Sabina.
Uh,
but also because Hadrian went around the empire and founded one Antonopoulos
after another.
There were tons of,
and,
and to Novelis is all Rome and he put up statues of antenna was in every
possible guys have every possible God,
the major Roman gods and some of and and all the minor Roman gods as well.
And there are lots of statues of aunt and it was,
this is another one that was founded,
the villa not at this pool,
although,
although it might have been given that the inspiration was Egypt.
Uh,
this shows him an Egyptian guys with the Egyptian headdress,
uh,
and uh,
covered covering all that wonderful curly hair,
uh,
for which he was so well known.
But nonetheless,
antenna was as a pharaoh from Hadrian's villa back to the Canopius.
You see the pool,
you see it has columns on one side.
These columns are had a sculpture interspersed in here.
Grease comes back to the fore because many of these statutes here,
we're also based on ancient Greek prototypes.
So we see this interesting.
Um,
eclecticism here.
I pool based on Egypt with some Egyptianize and statuary,
but also interspersed with Greek statues based on famous Greek prototypes.
Most important to us from the architectural standpoint,
the straight lentil and the RQ weighted lintel used here for the Canopius.
We saw that in second style Roman wall painting.
We're beginning to see it now in built architecture,
it becomes a particular favorite of Hadrian's and we're going to see it
elsewhere in the Roman provinces under Hadrian,
uh,
the influence again of Egypt and also in this case also of Rome to river gods
that seemed to have decorated the Canopius.
This one leaning on a figure of a sphinx.
So this is clearly the Nile River,
this one leaning on the,
she will suckling Romulus and Remus clearly the Tiber.
So once again,
very eclectic sculptural program,
the [inaudible] where they are to lining one side of the pool of the Canopius.
You see them over here now in the museum,
extremely well preserved based on the original fifth century BC,
Karrie audits on the Acropolis.
So Hadrian's spill hallel Leninism coming to the fore again,
you remember Augustus copied the same car,
he audits for his form reduced scale.
Hadrian's are in full length,
full scale,
same scale as those in Greece.
And the major difference between Hadrian's Karrie audits and Augustus's Augustus
is like the Eric theone with the original porch of the maidens in is in a public
building.
In the case of Hadrian,
a private villa using these curry audits at a private villa here you see them
lining one side of the Canopius flanked on either side by Seders,
the same kinds of fellows we saw and the Dionysiac mystery paintings.
And then just so that we don't forget Egypt,
uh,
this wonderful representation of a statue of a,
of a crocodile,
uh,
that was surely placed in the center of the pool peeping out of the water just
so that we make sure we remember it's the Nile.
Uh,
and I can trace my whole professional career.
I'm sitting on this crocodile because every time I'm there,
including even now I post on that crocodile,
but I do it in part because I think it's fun.
Uh,
but also big to encourage there.
There are two pictures that are really like students to send me when they travel
to Italy.
One is have them sitting on the crocodile at Hadrian's villa and another is them
on the stepping stones at palm pay.
So I hope if you do go that you will do that.
My favorite one and I can't find it unfortunate cause this is pre digital was a
student who sent me himself on this with his shades on,
but then he had put a cigarette in the mouth of the crocodile unlit cigarette
and then it was really a cool picture.
I've got to find that someday.
Uh,
the uh,
plan of the Canopius over here shows us what we've looked at.
The straight and RQ weighted lintel here,
the crocodile on this side,
the chorionic,
it's on that side.
And then over here at the end,
uh,
the temple of Cerasis because they were trying to recreate again this canal that
led from Alexandria to Canopius.
And at the end of course,
the temple of Syrup is the healing God that was located at Canopius.
But you can see as well as I by looking at the plan,
uh,
this curved structure over here,
which we'll see is made out of concrete that this is no Egyptian building.
This is a very modern,
uh,
Roman looking building.
And I show it to you here on the end of the canal.
This is called the so called Sarah pm or the temple of Syrup is,
and you can see it has one of Hadrian's pumpkin domes.
It is very likely that it was designed by,
by,
by him,
by Hadrian,
and we see it made out of concrete.
We can see it has niches that actually served as a fountain with very deep
niches from which there would have emanated a water display.
And then you can see a concrete dome up above with those segmented flat and
concave alternating flattened concave segments that look like a gourd or a
pumpkin dome probably designed by Hadrian himself.
Here's a closer view showing you the same
bats there.
Two baths at Hadrian's villa,
uh,
one of them,
um,
I show you the only,
the large beds here up Hadrian's villa,
which dates to the early phase of one 25 to one 33.
I'm not going to say too much about these,
I'm not going to show you the plan,
but just to make the point that the villa has not one but two baths and they are
Gargantuan.
Look at the size of this.
Look at the tourists here in relationship to the so called large bets.
This is a private bathing establishment,
but it shows you that Hadrian has learned well from Trajan.
This is if Fraijanes forum was the mother of all forums.
This is the mother of all private bath buildings that we see at a Hadrian's
villa.
And we also see the expert way in which these architects use concrete
construction.
It's extraordinary.
Look at these vaults vaults that are springing just as they did in Hadrian's
market hall,
uh,
in the markets in Rome,
springing from a groin bolts and spring from a bracket,
uh,
rather than from a column or a Pilaster and look at the way in which they've
been able to open up this wall.
D materialize the wall with very large windows,
very sophisticated use of concrete construction here,
a detail of the groin vaults springing from the bracket with the stucco
decoration that you can also see very quickly.
I also want to show you,
um,
the,
uh,
the so called Piatsa Doro or the Golden Plaza,
which dates also to the early phase of the villa of Hadrian activity one 25 to
one 33.
You can see just by looking at its plan that it's interesting.
It was used as a,
an audience hall when Hadrian greeted important visitors at the villa.
Uh,
if you look at the entrance vestibule,
it's octagonal just like the octagonal room of rebellious,
uh,
with a pumpkin vault.
Then a great open rectangular space,
fairly traditional surrounded by columns.
And then over here,
the audience hall or our law Aula itself,
this is,
this is an amazing structure.
And what makes the Owlet particularly interesting and important is like the
Pantheon.
It combines traditional and innovative architecture.
It combines concrete construction with traditional vocabulary of Greek
architecture,
namely columns.
There is an annual or vault over here.
Uh,
you can see that the walls of the structure undulate but this undulation is
particularly interesting because the walls are not made out of concrete.
Uh,
we'll see that the walls are made out of columns here.
I show you,
uh,
a cutaway axonometric view of the hour law where you can see these undulating
walls making a kind of cruciform shape,
but you can see that they are supported by columns.
So again,
this fascinating a bringing together of the traditional vocabulary of Greek
architecture,
namely columns with a concrete pumpkin dome on top use of innovative,
uh,
of the traditional vocabulary of architecture and an innovative way.
One might even call this an example of the so called Baroque trend in Roman
antiquity,
which we'll be talking about increasingly.
And I want you to be aware that you had that it happens here just very quickly.
The very sculptural vestibule entranceway so inspired by [inaudible] of the
Piazza,
Doro showing this concrete construction with a pumpkin dome,
uh,
and then a detail of some of the columns along that undulating that curve or
undulating wall that are still preserved in the outlet.
I,
I want to show you also lastly at Hadrian's villa,
the so called a tro tro Marie Timo,
the maritime theater,
which dates to the very earliest of the phases,
one 18 to one 28.
This was the building I hydrea and started with this first because this is what
he wanted most of all,
which was an island villa within a villa,
a place where he could really go if you wanted to be alone,
even at his own villain.
One can imagine him escaping here,
uh,
with an antenna was by his side.
Uh,
we see that island villa here.
It's a round structure,
uh,
in order to protect himself.
Once he crossed the drawbridge,
he has placed a moat around the,
uh,
around the island villa within a villa.
But if you look at the plan of that island villa,
you would think that Roberto was,
was still alive.
You know,
in the sense of that,
that compass work that we saw Burberry is doing in the private wing of the
Domus.
Al was down a playing off,
convex against concave.
Uh,
but the difference between this and what [inaudible] did is this combines in
this very exciting way,
concrete walls with a and concrete domes with columns.
We see that same combination here.
Here's a view of what the island within the,
uh,
the [inaudible] Marie Timo looks like today.
Here's the island surrounded by the moat.
And you can see this wonderful combination of brick,
face,
concrete construction with columns.
But if you look at the columns,
you will see that they follow the curvature of the foundation of the wall.
So this again,
combination of traditional and innovative architecture,
another view of the mode of a colonnade with ionic capitals that surrounds the
hall.
And then another view of the island part,
uh,
with this wonderful interaction of columnar and concrete architecture.
Lastly,
I just want to show you the,
uh,
tomb of Hadrian and make a very few points about it.
The tomb of Hadrian,
the famous Maza Liam of Hadrian,
better known as the [inaudible] Angelo in Rome,
was put up at the end of Hadrian's reign,
uh,
between one 35 and his death in one 38 and consecrated by his successor Antonius
Pius.
It is located in the part of Rome that we have not explored thus far because
very few ancient buildings survive from that part of the city.
We are looking at an excellent Google earth view of the Tiber river.
You will notice,
uh,
the,
Piazza Navona over here,
the great stadium over here,
and we should be able to see the Pantheon,
but it may be cut off as is,
uh,
the,
um,
in this view as is the tomb of,
of Augustus,
which is located over here.
But we can see,
well the [inaudible] Angelo of Hadrian's Mazda Liam fronted by a bridge over the
Tiber and that's the Vatican II Vatican City upright above.
So Hadrian chose a location across the Tiber where there were some imperial
gardens for his tomb.
Here you can better see also Google earth of view of the castle son Angelo as it
looks today.
The walls and the watch towers were added later because this served as a
fortress for the pope's,
uh,
when the pope in the Vatican,
the pope's in bad times,
they had an underground passageway that they could scurry from the Vatican two,
this fortress where they could be protected.
And that's when the watch towers and so on were added.
As you can see here,
fronted by a bridge.
This is the famous Pont de San Angelo,
uh,
designed by Bernini,
the great 17th century architect Bernini with a series of angels and hear
another view of the castle son Angela with Bernini's angels on the bridge.
The most important point for us as you can see,
that although a tombs round tombs were no longer oh core round in the second
century,
a d they had gone out of fashion,
remember tightest,
buried in his arch,
Trajan buried in his column.
They really weren't doing round tombs at the extent that they had been doing
earlier.
Hadrian chooses this.
Why?
Because the Great Mazal Liam of Augustus was around to him.
He wants to associate himself with Augustus and he wants to create a new tomb
for a succession of dynasties.
Nervo was the last to be buried in the mausoleum of Augustus Hadrian,
the first in this Mazal Liam,
which became be continued to be used in the second century.
And so it uses the mausoleum of Augustus and the Cecilia Metalla Tomb as models.
We have seen this model here of the tomb of a,
of Hadrian.
Uh,
it's round made out of concrete placed as the Cecilia metalla tune was on a
podium,
a very tall podium,
probably a tool Mulas on top earth into a Mulas like Augustus is to them.
We don't know what happened at the very apex,
whether there was a statue of Hadrian or a temple like structure as you see
here.
But the most important point for us is that at the end of his life,
Hadrian is,
is continuing to connect himself to Rome's first emperor to Augustus.
Both of them in perpetuity,
uh,
filled Hellenic emperors with Phil Hellenic leanings.
But in the case of both of them,
and particularly Hadrian,
he combines it with this new concrete architecture in a very special,
very distinctive way that will have a lasting impact on architecture in the
Roman Empire.